je suis à saint lô dans la manche
je vais aller rencontrer mathieu lebrun
c'est le patron du milton la discothèque
qui se trouve juste derrière moi depuis
le 10 décembre elle est fermée comme
toutes les discothèques de france alors
comment elle les patrons de discothèques
ont-ils vécu à nouveau cette fermeture
dans quel état d'esprit sont ils on va
aller lui demander
bonjour mathieu
merci beaucoup de nous recevoir chez
vous alors vous êtes vous est fermé
depuis le 10 décembre maintenant comment
comment s'est passée cette nouvelle
fermeture va écouter on a ouvert le
mercredi et le jeudi ce qui est on est
encore dans l'autorisation ce qui nous a
permis d'écouler nos stocks veut dire au
revoir à nos clients et parce que bon
ils ont beau nous expliquer qu'on va
fermer quatre semaines on est tous à peu
près conscient que ça va durer plus
longtemps que quatre semaines alors je
sais bien que c'est qu'on veut c'est
compliqué pour eux de gérer cette
épidémie mais on a quand même tous le
sentiment que c'est pas une décision
sanitaire de nous fermer c'est une
décision politique qu'est-ce que qu'est
ce qui vous fait dire ça et qu'est ce
que cela signifie concrètement pour vous
qui nous fait dire ça c'est que ont
ouvert depuis le puy 9 juillet
alors au tout début on a parlé de
quelques cents les boîtes de nuit a
priori au retour de ce conseil que nos
syndicats et il ya eu 14 cluster depuis
le 9 juillet dans les boîtes de nuit
alors j'en ai eu un donc c'est à dire
que ma capacité d'accueil à ce moment là
était de 525 personnes huit personnes
contaminées on appelle ça un cluster
voilà comment on parle on n'a pas
l'impression d'avoir été plus dangereux
qu'une autre activité oui on a du mal à
comprendre et est ce qu on dit tous tous
les patrons bonne nuit qu'on soit fermé
ou ouvert la fête aura lieu j'imagine
que vous avez à d'autant plus de mal à
comprendre cette fermeture que dans les
discothèques le pen sanitaires et est
contrôlé et j'ai envie de dire sur
contrôler parce que vous demandez aussi
les présidences c'est un peu long je
vous propose qu'on s'assoit
c'est très difficile à comprendre
sachant qu'on avait quand même la plus
haute protection c'est à dire qu'on nous
a expliqué leur ouverture alors vous
même pas sanitaire vous devez et on a
été contrôlé et lourd devant contrôler
pendant toute la période d'ouverture
dans un restaurant on arrive on montre
un pass pas de pièces d'identité ça peut
être le passe de n'importe qui et ça
rentre dans les discothèques c'est pas
du tout qui avoue contrôler
automatiquement les identités des gens
toute manière pour le milton j'ai eu six
contrôles six fois ils sont venus voir
si on a bien tester les si on a bien
fait le test des passes à lithaire des
gens en nous refermons nous aussi un
peut-être un aveu de diamal pas
sanitaire marche pas je pense que ça
fonctionne je pense que c'est bien mais
elle est malheureusement ça va laisser
entendre au grand public elle te rends
compte les boîtes de mise a les plus
gros contrôle ils ont fermé et pourtant
vous avez le truc avec ba sanitaires
plus prisés l'entité qu'elle quel
message on envoie aux gens ou dans quel
état d'esprit ce que vous êtes
aujourd'hui c'est de la colère c'est
c'est quoi sur la première période sous
les premiers six mois on est passé un
peu partout il y avait beaucoup plus de
colère sur la première période avant
qu'on auront hélas il ya de la colère
mais fut
dans l'ensemble je vais moi le premier
je suis plus blasés blasé fatigué
fatigué des décisions qui sont prises
l'édition je reviens toujours le bon
sens il y en a plus il y la fête aura
lieu il ya des gens qui vont organiser
des soirées des soirées clandestines
l'état y perdant dans tous les sens
c'est à dire que sanitairement parce
qu'il y aura pas de contrôle de pas sali
terrain du tout et puis il ya surtout
que ces soirées clandestines sont
payantes et l'état vont perdre aussi
économiques parce que quand je suis
ouvert je paye de la tva de l'urssaf des
charges diverses et variées que je
redistribue à l'état des impôts
bas ça pilotes et en plus ils vont nous
aider financièrement incroyable
nature on arrivait dans le centre
névralgique de la boîte de nuit du moins
pour vous c'est la caisse ce qui m'amène
à vous demander qu'est-ce que comment ça
va se passer cette fois au niveau des
aides de l'état qu'est ce que l'état
vous a promis alors le chômage partiel
on va voir le coût fixe c'est à dire
qu'ils prennent toutes les charges la
discothèque et la rémunération du gérant
et on va dire à peu près alléluia parce
que on s'est débrouillé pendant 16 mois
sur la première période où on n'avait
pas de salaire nous légion mais ce qu'il
faut voir c'est alors ce qui est pas mon
cas moi j'ai eu une discothèque qui
fonctionne sur les douze mois à peu près
avec des pics un peu plus importants que
d'autres mais je pense à mes collègues
saisonniers
on va prendre les discothèques qui sont
en stations de montagne qui pendant
cette période c'est le moment où ils
vont gagner leur argent et là on va leur
payer que les coûts fixes comment
vont-ils faire cet été où ils sont
fermés vous aviez imaginé vous retrouver
à nouveau dans cette étude on savait que
juillet ou de septembre
on allait
nous lâcher un peu la grappe évidemment
pensé au moment où le froid les revenir
et que l'épidémie allait et j j'avais
toujours ça dans le coin de ma tête et
comme je le dis en plus on sert toujours
un peu de bouc émissaire c'est
psychologiquement dur on parle
d'ailleurs de ta voix ça devient cesse
je suis désolé du terme ça devient
chiant khl mais je pense que c'est un
peu le mot que tous les français doivent
pensais pas que les patrons de boîte de
nuit
merci beaucoup merci à vous